hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to let's play Lone Survivor
now this has been on my list for a while
because it's a very highly reviewed uh
indie horror game for its atmosphere and
just general storytelling so I'm gonna
get into it right away I've already
looked into the menu there's really no
other option besides a new game here
it's by a guy named Jasper beer Byron
b-y-r-n-e
and I don't know much about the game
other than that you're the Lone Survivor
my name is
my name is what not important anymore I
guess
then
hello
how long I'd been here
now I've got no idea
been a while since the outbreak started
that much I know
holed up with the sound of those things
outside
monsters I guess you'd call them
as far as I know I'm the only one left
the Lone Survivor
which is the name of the game if you
were paying attention can't go on much
longer though almost out of supplies and
if there's anyone else alive out there I
need to find them
if nothing else I don't want to die
alone
all right so this game is in a pixelated
style but it's not an RPG horror game it
is a custom made game as you can see
yeah
anyway
hello I love the music in the intro
there and uh
this isn't bad itself
hello
what is that is that a
is that a lamp or is that a guy with a
box on his head I don't want to sit down
right now
looks like a double espresso
drink the coffee
oh is this the first choice like in the
Stanley Parable go right or left I need
to stay awake I'll drink the coffee
I don't really like coffee myself whoa
what just happened
I think I can hear something down there
was it the Box head
something down where
where are you now
I'm not entirely sure what's going on
anymore well why
ah okay
what
what's going on here that's what I'd
like to know
what is that oh is that one of the
monsters okay
damn it's one of those things
I don't think you can see me wait looks
like there's a hiding spot just behind
it if I can sneak past
wait what
ah
okay I got it so there's like a slight I
can barely see it but there's like a
slight indentation in the wall
and I can move on okay so that's
probably a pretty important game
mechanic that I need to know I might as
well go through
to where why look talk to her wait a
minute you just said you're a lone
survivor she can't be real
hello
hello
oh boy
hello
are you okay I'm gonna guess no
what's that you're holding
what
I got some kind of pocket flashlight I
pick up whatever the ghosty goo girl
just dropped on the floor do I look do I
look more Sinister wait knowing how to
do
okay Scott I I picked up something let's
try switching it on
oh
I
I got a pounding headache
damn night terrors no better than the
days
why is this like I Am Legend well good
morning flashlight old friend
all right then it's time to face the
outside world
if you say so man
pick up green pill got some kind of
green medicine so that's like a Resident
Evil mechanic let's see if I can get
anything
we the survivors praying for in 203
that's all I could get I wonder if I
should head for 203 first
maybe there's someone alive in there
every diary
let's have a look
nothing exciting happened today tried to
eat an insect I caught but it's no use
since it's just me now I have to get out
of here I need to find a weapon
something long rains as sons of [ __ ]
are too dangerous up close there's tons
of [ __ ] and I don't want to hear their
nasty disease getting on me
then maybe I can get me something to eat
oh I remembered where I put their key
it's on the sofa in the living room I
don't know where the key for the bedroom
is though
that's the latest entry
well bugs are actually high in protein
and quite nutritious for you there's
something written on the door in the
faint chalk
read it okay let's see
X to interact and shoot C is weapon mode
toggle walk inventory and or walk
inventory in the space is open inventory
save game use your bed flashlight toggle
quick weapon reload enters map right hey
whoa God ass gamma
qw aspect e is expert mode I don't know
I don't think I want that P is pause one
ignite flare two Place rotting meat
three drink Health tonic well that's all
lovely that's a lot to take in
ah it's locked I need a key to open it
but good thing I have a key on the sofa
got a battery
I don't know whose it is
well then you've been living here for a
while these aren't mine
why don't you not know what things are
look deeply into the mirror well this is
what got me in trouble and knock knock
but let's go for it I don't see anything
special wait
it feels like it's trying to draw me to
some other place
oh well that's normal but it doesn't
know where it wants to that to be oh so
that's like a quick port
to chunk I need the key to open it
okay what's in here aha pick up the
front door key
to 206 so that's where I left it
the fridge wait what's that smell even
with my mask on is making me dizzy
what it is and it hardly bear to touch
this it's piles of rotting meat I'll
take six piles of meat for only six
giant piles I mean let me just cram
those into my pockets here down my pants
whatever
it's the most I could handle oh I can
handle a lot more meat than that my
stove I don't remember it happening but
it's run out of gas I'll have to find
some more
there's some kind of cat plush on here
might as well take it
okay I got a diary page well that's good
I guess can I read that I might need
that
look at no don't don't look at it read
it no don't close it read it it reads I
can't trust any of them anymore any of
those bastards could be diseased there's
only one way to survive this and that's
to put a bullet in every last one of
their heads we all know what I'm saying
is the truth let's not try and deny it
anymore I'll be waiting with the
survivors
there's a name at the bottom Draco I
don't know the person who wrote this I'm
more interested in the other survivors
if there are any are you Draco
are you the one that's going psycho
Bonkers crazy use the Kio to 206 I'll
get rid of it now
I should probably get some sleep before
I go out there I don't want to forget
what I'm doing
what does that mean it's locked I need a
key to open it okay I think I collected
everything that I needed to weren't you
just asleep though
I don't know
we sleep anyway
I guess I think it's too late for that
off you go then
I feel a little better
game saved okay so the game does save
every time you sleep but now it's night
time outside did I really want that
I hear one of those days
got the map of wing Court 2f
I hear a thing it's in my headphones
look like there's something already
marked on here let's take a look
okay so I'm in 206 the colored doors are
the ones that I've looked at the mirrors
will help get me to places I need to get
to 203.
all right I guess the blue is me
that's where cheese place wasn't it why
would anyone mark it on here I'll try
and make my way there anyway
how long this guy's been in this place
oh yeah that letter was pinned to the
map
read it now who cares if there's a
monster right down there might as well
read the letter then don't set off
without a map even if you do know your
way around things keep changing you see
by the way I think I have a way to get
past those things I worked out they're
attracted to the center Decay when I'm
having trouble getting past them I'll
leave some rotting meat down to one side
of a hiding spot then I can hide as they
come towards me
best to avoid them you see there's no
signature on it okay lastly that's right
okay where's the hiding spot
wait I can hear something down there not
taking my chances without a gun gonna
switch my flashlight off try to sneak
past
hide oh
so stupid ah crap okay so
they said I needed to play some running
meat here
how do I okay
there we go running me need to place
don't eat it that's what would happen if
I eat no I'm not gonna eat what would
happen if I no I'm not gonna eat it
place it
was hanging me down
ah buddy how you doing okay
what
Oh I thought it got me uh or zombie what
does that say
apartment 205 oh
I'm kind of some good books in there
collecting borrowed a few in my time
so you've just been wandering through
this place man
this monsters about I don't think it's a
good idea
oh it was a good idea to sleep before
crumpled old no let's look at that
read I strongly advise against listening
to Draco a man's danger to What's Left
of society it may be right that you need
to defend yourself when there's no other
solution but what I'm trying to say is
there are always other ways around the
problem than violence think on it
there's no signature at the bottom
I'm beginning to think that you're Draco
that's my first guess they only make
things you hear hear you coming
what
they only make things hear you coming oh
shoes oh okay
what do you mean whoa
disgusting
there's a hole no it's just my
imagination what the hell is that
don't enter the hole
I'd have to be crazy to want to go in
there well I am pretty crazy
so let's go marching on in
okay here goes nothing
oh why did I
who's that
I saw something it was circlish and
circular
and big
Boosie oh
why am I in this hole
the bad feeling about this
oh it was just a circle on the screen
like film grain
what
I'm losing myself I shouldn't have gone
in this hole man
oh I hear a thing
I I heard a thing
it seems to God now
hello
okay whoa
there's no way this is still my
apartment block
oh
you dick bag
get Jesus what is that thing is that
some sort of biomass
oh God why did I go in this hole
I don't think I wanted any part of this
any part of any of this any of this I
did not want
ah
ah I'm through
I thought it was never gonna end
hey there's another mirror it looks like
just like the one in my apartment
ah dried Squid on a stick
that's good I guess
I guess that would uh wait hang on where
am I
oh really
the hole went there
but I guess the mirror could help me get
to where I need to go
oh man the sound hey I got food bag of
prawn crackers
oh hi buddy
I need to turn off my flashlight that's
right
damn [ __ ]
okay all right okay they're wondering
what that writing is on the uh
ah there was a hole in the way I had to
go through the hole
I wonder damn I'm gonna have to creep
past this once if I can just get behind
it that is oh
oh oh
so are these things blind I don't quite
think so because
there's uh
they uh are attracted to light
I don't need to waste me
dude
okay here we go
I think this is the entrance to 204 but
the number's been removed it's locked
maybe I should try later try later what
does that even mean
who's gonna open it where am I now
all right exhausted
so I'm exhausted I need to sleep piece
of paper three some kind of diary page
let's take a look
no that's not right no no no that wasn't
it diary page three there it is no God
dang it it reads I only come out at
night that's simple Common Sense they're
more docile and there's less of them
anyway I found if I pop them right in
the head with my Colt they fall to the
floor like sacks of old skinny jelly of
skinny jelly other things I note
wait a minute that didn't register for a
second
someone laughing at me I'm not funny
damn it I wish that was funnier all
other things I noticed is once they get
up in your grill it's best to shoot them
in the legs so they come back off a bit
it's satisfying too Draco
well Draco seems like a Survivor type so
I'm assuming that's me
they're destroyed there's no I'm getting
down there I'll have to try the other
side of the building this is really
I think by the way I have to say
I mean I've learned a greater
appreciation for uh
older style games and you know I've been
watching a lot of game grumps lately and
they've been playing a lot of old games
that's pretty much what they do and and
you know it kind of goes back to my
child this is this Duo three isn't it
I'm in 203 I didn't think I'd get here
this early
I'm not going in their bedroom yet why
not
Fortune hello you banging in here can I
join you I'm very lonely bedside table
smells of perfume I'm not going to look
in there why
not going what it's got a woman's touch
it's the books and a few pieces of paper
got a weird old doll
but anyway yeah like my childhood was
filled with uh playing these old games
don't need anything from their bathroom
playing these old games so you know it's
more accustomed for me to see these
types of games and appreciate it for
what it is as opposed to like uh say a a
modern game with super awesome graphics
and I've been like keeping track I've
seen the progression so it's amazing for
me to watch all the tech demos and stuff
like that but whoa
so I'm not right here
I'm not right here
I'm not right
going on not letting you out there yet
why not you know when yet
why not
hi
did you bring her doll I don't want to
talk about that talk about what until
you show me you can even hold it let
alone talk about it I've got nothing
else to say to you but but this
obviously isn't real you think it's safe
to party here
I feel pretty safe
there's monsters out there
you must have seen them the Hideous
creatures out there
let's relax for a minute shall we trying
to save you I'm quite safe I assure you
don't I know you Benzito was your name
wasn't it there's nothing wrong with
your memory I think you should go home
to your parents now I don't think this
is helping very funny but you won't be
laughing soon they'll get in here you
see party always needs guests little man
wouldn't be a party otherwise so this
guy isn't exactly an adult he's a kid
why are you just sitting around at a
time like this lovely party isn't
it lovely party what's your problem
it's obvious I don't know you held out
this long
would you like another dream you try the
juice it's out of this world
is it Jungle Juice
so
that's weird
that's okay hang on she wanted
the doll
give there you go then thanks for that I
know it must have been hard for you I
don't know what you're talking about you
don't huh well I have what you asked for
meet me outside when you're ready for it
I don't know what you're saying
meet me outside oh oh I got it the
outside that she was not letting me do
okay
gee it's okay just take it what the hell
are you talking about the gun over there
so you realize I need the protection at
least
I'm not one to judge
gun over where get over here ah
handgun
and she's gone
if I guess wait where'd she go
see weapon mode exit I'm not gonna waste
my ammo right now [ __ ] aim up name
down or up
headshot leg shot body shot body shot
probably doesn't do much
I don't know how much ammo I got because
he's a Devastation for miles around what
happened here
how did the disease begin to spread it
makes me sick well that's what diseases
do
okay
oh
they partied a little too Hardy got no
choice but to take him down okay wait
shooting mode up
flam
my I said blam
huh
that took some more shots than I would
have liked oh God
oh there was a party going on five
minutes ago I'm a bit worried I'm not in
good shape
yeah no joke
what the hell just happened to me
okay all right so this guy is obviously
going insane oh good
Devastation I don't know what just
happened here I don't really want to
think too deeply on it I need to find a
way out of these apartments if I can
make it to the other choir right there
okay that one over there looks like
there's nothing stopping me from going
around the hallway
so fair way to the stairs
I guess I'll just have to look around
this area see what I can find
okay
I could show you some sleep first though
are you sure about that buddy
what did I get beef jerky all right
what happened here what happened to you
what happened
hello
really happened to you
they're a whole behind it let's try
pushing it I don't want to go in the
hole
can't I take a knee up
huh
we're just gonna we're just gonna it's
not that interesting to you
oh there was a oh
what is that
the map
wait a minute isn't that mine
206. oh yeah
Department I'm staying in wait didn't I
remember that anyway I probably can
probably get back via the mirror
because
that's normal is that blocking up a hole
starving I need to eat let's eat
something Nom Noms
uh not the rotting meat prawn crackers
let's eat that oh wait there's more
like shrimp crackers
we're good crispy
from
okay look deeply into it I'm doing all
right
and I'm teleporting okay
what just happened to me did I black out
or something I don't know how I got here
but I guess it's good to be home
yeah I'm wondering if even this home is
okay
use bed to sleep now I'll have a snooze
night night light
night little lady
day three I feel a little better
game's saved all right so that's all the
time I have for now I need food but I'll
get it later that's all the time I have
for now let me know what you think of
this game in the comments below and my
initial reactions are that it's really
cool it's very atmospheric the story is
very interesting I'm I'm eager to learn
more about this guy and that's what's
really important about a story gaming
and I gotta say it's trippy as hell it's
drippy it's
creativity's put more through uh the
environment than the than the actual
Graphics of it and it's not the graphics
so bad they fit the game very well so
long as gameplay matches up that's all I
care about thanks so much for watching
Click The annotation for more videos and
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
where's the black man
I'm gonna use this rake on the ladder